deutschlands fußball auf dem höhepunkt
seines erfolgs
deutsche top stars werden von
internationalen spitzenvereinen gejagt
die talent quelle sprudelt immer weiter
nicht ohne grund
dahinter steckt ein millionenschweres
system es beginnt im jahr 2000
deutschland scheidet bei der
europameisterschaft in belgien und den
niederlanden bereits in der vorrunde
das team hat ein durchschnittsalter von
31 5 jahren junge talente sind nicht in
sicht
natürlich ist die em 2000 schon sozial
finden gewesen
für die verantwortlichen dass sie etwas
machen müssen dass wir reagieren müssen
die nachwuchsförderung wird 2001 auf den
kopf gestellt vertreter des deutschen
fußball bundes und der bundesliga
vereine treffen sich wenige monate nach
dem em debakel und beschließen
umfassende reformen mit einem jährlichen
investitionsvolumen von zehn millionen
euro soll der weg zurück in die
weltspitze eingeschlagen werden
das b&b system greift erstmals bei den
elf- bis zwölfjährigen karl ist einer
der besten spieler in seinem verein und
wurde von dfb sichtungs trainern
entdeckt der berliner möchte
nationalspieler werden wie tausende
andere kinder in seinem alter aber ich
habe eine passqualität technik in ganz
deutschland sorgen rund 1300
honorartrainer an 366 stützpunkten dafür
dass kein talent mehr unentdeckt bleibt
die junge elite wird gefördert und
gefordert
nach hause lernen vielleicht noch ein
ganz bisschen und dann geht's eigentlich
schon wieder zum training und dann
möchte eigentlich dass ganz viel damit
zusammen wie man spielt das gesicht um
das ist einfach wesentlich
professioneller geworden ist dass
umfangreicher geworden ist dass man sich
noch viel viel mehr gedanken macht auch
über talent prognosen talent entwicklung
aber ich glaube dass immer schon darauf
geachtet wurde wer kann sich durchsetzen
hier interessiert uns nur was heute in
zehn jahren eventuell herauskommen kann
denn dann sollen die bundesligavereine
von der sichtung profitieren
sie übernehmen die besten gesichteten in
ihre nachwuchsleistungszentren deren
infrastruktur sie jährlich 130 millionen
euro investieren
der fc schalke 04 betreibt eines der
erfolgreichsten leistungszentren hier
wurden stars wie manuel neuer und mesut
özil groß
wir spielen heute eben nicht mehr auf
den ascheplätzen sondern wir haben die
möglichkeit viel viel besser auszubilden
sie erinnern deutschland ist immer
gesagt worden hat sich die titel
erarbeitet das ist auch wichtig von der
mentalität her aber mittlerweile wenn
man die 2014 mannschaften sind wir eben
auch fußballerisch sehr gut um in
zukunft nicht wieder von der konkurrenz
überholt zu werden hat der dfb voraus
geplant im jahr 2017 entsteht auf diesem
gelände in frankfurt am main das
selbstbetitelte jahrhundertprojekt die
dfb akademie
hier sollen die bereiche ausbildung
leistungssport und forschung zusammen
kommen ein fußball sinkt die dfb bosse
wollen immer mehr und immer bessere
talente produzieren um im
internationalen vergleich zu bestehen
schon kinder wie kahl sind eine
potenzielle wertanlage die der deutsche
fussball frühzeitig investiert
nichts wird mehr dem zufall überlassen
die professionalisierung des
jugendfußballs ist in vollem gange
finanzielle mittel werden dafür nicht
gescheut alles für den erfolg